today it is my incredible pleasure to
introduce our special guests we have
four recent alumni who come from our
fellowship programs so they are all
involved with very interesting
entrepreneurial ventures and they've
been invited to participate with us
because the diversity of what they're
doing and the passion that they bring to
these projects we have Cody coots who is
a dfj entre leader and he graduated just
last year did ya yeah we've got Elaine
Chang who was a mayfield fellow a few
years ago when did you graduate yeah I'm
not a recent graduate yeah a class of
9999 ok we have Tasha cave and she was
an excel innovation scholar and what
year did you graduate officially last
year I turned in my thesis and Jonah
greenberger who is also a mayfield
fellow so please join me in welcoming
our special guest so I thought that it
would be really helpful to have each of
them introduce themselves just give a
little bit about their background what
they studied and what they're doing now
to set the stage so who wants to start
well sorry yeah I'm Cody I studied
symbolic systems I'm Cody I studied
symbolic systems here i graduated in
june and now i work as head of creative
ATS driver labs which is a performance
training virtual reality startup that
came out of research here at Stanford hi
my name is Elaine trung I did my
undergrad here at Stanford and
biological sciences and then I did my co
term in ms any in the steno mentioned I
was Mayfield Fellows program as well I'm
at a company called Grail and what we're
trying to do is analyze circulating
nucleic acid in the blood in order to
try to be able to detect cancer early I
am Tasha cave and I did my masters and
PhD here I was in the mechanical
engineering department however my
advisor was in chemical engineering and
while I was here I participated in the
Excel Scholars Program I also did ignite
the summer program in the GSB we also
were in this Stanford venture studio we
did start XO done a lot of
entrepreneurship things here at Stanford
and the company that we
arted i have two of the co-founders who
also were stanford grass we started a
company called opus 12 and what opens 12
does is recycle co2 so we make reactors
that input carbon dioxide and water and
then using metal catalysts and
electricity we break attempt we break
down the co2 in wall into smaller atomic
bits and then reform those are taunted
bits into a new molecule and we can make
one of 16 new molecules I'll just co2 in
water and these include things like a
precursor to the diesel fuel to plastics
common household chemicals and the idea
is that we can provide an economic
incentive for companies utilize their
co2 instead of just throwing it away
[Music]
awesome Jonah greenberger I was stanford
class of 08 I don't know if classes do
that anymore the little oh wait chant
but had I started a company called
bright two and a half years ago and we
provide cheaper electricity to homes in
developing countries with rooftop solar
subscriptions so pretty impressive right
so I got a lot of students come to me
recently and must be that time of years
the students are thinking about
graduating you know at the end of this
year and thinking about what they're
gonna do next and they're trying to
figure out what drives them and it'd be
really helpful to know from you guys
what motivated you to get involved with
the endeavors that you're working on now
min so for example Cody this is right
out of school as as for you Tasha yeah
yeah for me I really found myself in a
place where there was a identifiable use
case for the virtual reality industry I
happen to be studying VR at a time where
I was exploding so a little bit before
what we see now and another student here
at Stanford came to me and had this
really great idea which was the first
time that I thought there was an actual
real quality use case for VR and this
was kind of before the explosion in the
industry so what motivated me was just
being excited about a use case that I
thought was a tremendous application
right Natasha you also started right
after school yeah and actually we start
a little bit before I graduated we
working in our free time you know but
before I finished to figure out what
we're going to do for the company how
we're going to make this economically
viable
and for me it really just was i I was
doing this research here i loved it i
gave me a huge sense of purpose and i
really want to see if it could work in
the real world so my other co-founder
Kendra we did our page she two gether we
were in the same lab we just started
writing down ideas of how we could
actually scale up the technology my PhD
was mostly focus on the basic science
side so we wrote papers and we looked at
things on a very fundamental level and
this is kind of the other side of that
of the applied side of like how do you
make it cheaper and more cost-effective
and how do you make the economics work
so really just stem for interest in like
wanting to do the technology not seeing
anyone in the bay area or the side of
the country that had worked in this area
and so we thought well you know if not
us then who I don't need to see if we
can make this work so I was two and a
half years ago so it's really
interesting because Joan and Elaine you
have a really different story I believe
Jonah you had a passion for doing
something meaningful in the solar space
but you made a really different decision
about how to go about it first yeah so
you kind of led me into this but it so
energy is an interesting field you need
some industry experience it's like a
very global industry with a lot of
regulations so I actually when I was
graduating I did the Mayfield Fellows
Program and then I decided to go to the
largest company I could to learn about
business and I had studied mechanical
engineering so I went to Chevron which
was doing some interesting stuff in
cleantech and I went there to learn the
processes that make a company tick at
scale and what regulations work and what
makes a company successful I kind of in
the energy industry and I was there for
longer than I thought I was there for
about five years but I learned a ton and
then started bright right after that one
of the reasons actually was this is kind
of a more big quote but I think on
people's deathbed the number one thing
they regret is not taking a risk and so
I read that once and it kind of haunted
me and I was at chevron and it was
haunting me and you know once I felt
like I'd been there and I started to get
enough courage I just decided like I
didn't want it I didn't want to be that
person on my deathbed that had not
the risk and did what I wanted to do so
that's kind of how this all started
great anyway yes a similar to the energy
industry which takes a lot of capital is
highly regulated it's been my passion
since I was a kid to be in the life
sciences industry so after school a
couple of the opportunities that I went
to or being at the industry leader for
molecular diagnostics in oncology to
help cancer patients guide their
treatment decisions and then went to the
industry leader in DNA sequencing
technologies and spent several years at
both of those organizations kind of
learning the space and really learning
you know the domain and but you know
wanted to get back to an autumn or kind
of startup opportunity where I could be
very close to developing products for
the patients and so really I'm Grail is
an opportunity for us to do that to
leverage you know really really exciting
technologies to be able to improve
patient lives so we know that starting a
company or being involved with the
startup is full of surprises and often
you know pits that you fall into as well
as really fabulous highs have there been
already some surprises that you could
share with us you know obviously you
started with the idea that okay this is
going to be fabulous and great but what
happened that might have surprised you
along the way Cody you'd want to start
yeah for us we're surprised that so we
build a training tool for professional
athletes to use VR to train and we're
always surprised that that coaches don't
want to use the tool I think the biggest
surprise for me is how important sales
is is to our cycle is to actually try to
sell this tool because to us I mean we
are a company of athletes and and sports
minded folk but the sales process is so
important to the industry and I think
the biggest surprise was just how how
hard we need to work at that so instead
of proving it as a tool it's always
about kind of pitching it to kind of how
how do they use it in a way that is
effective for them and how do we pitch
it to them as something that's going to
be non-invasive to their current
coaching philosophies so interesting you
sort of thought if we build that they
will come
exactly dad you learned that that was
something about this is not the case yes
so we're still working okay right Elaine
thanks I think generally speaking the
the genomics industry and the technology
that's been developing over the last
decade has been moving extraordinarily
quickly the the cost per sequencing a
base pair is dropping much much faster
than Moore's Law exponentially faster in
fact and so it's really enabled this
technology to be applied in a clinical
setting now very rapidly so I think at a
meta-level that's been a surprise to all
of us in terms of how quickly that
technology is developed but I think for
us at the start of a morir very mission
driven company and so the the rate at
which we've been growing but we have a
company value of GSD oh just get stuff
done it's just been a phenomenal
experience over the last several months
to see how much a group of really smart
like-minded mission-driven folks can get
done and so as an example we brought on
our first wave of hires in March and by
August we've already started we had
already started enrolling in our first
clinical trial which will end up in
rolling over 10,000 subjects and just
the pace at which that has happened is
is pretty unprecedented in the oncology
space and so that's been a very pleasing
surprise for all of us right so good
surprise yeah I think for for me the big
surprise was you know when we were first
starting this and kind of working in the
evenings figuring things out I sort of
naively thought that oh you know we're
with three Stanford students you know we
have to to technical co-founders in one
business co-founder and someone will
give us an initial amount of money to
get out there and get going and then we
you know like the later stage funding
would be the harder part the first funny
would be really like easy and that
turned out to not be the case at all
like no one really want to give us any
money because we had no prototype we
just had an idea and I had a decent
story and so what we had to do was end
up getting government funding to build
our initial prototype and and in general
we've had to diversify the streams in
which we've raised
money so we've also looked at
philanthropy and family offices and and
kind of to get us the stage where we
would be attractive to like venture
funding at a later later point we're so
not not there yet we're bringing an
angel investors in that type of thing
but we're not quite ready for a venture
capital funding and so that has been
like the most surprising part of like
you hear all these stories about oh you
know a couple students got their initial
seed funding right out of school and
then could take off and that for a clean
tech company and doing hardware that's
not the case so I was surprised by how
many people will tell you that you can't
do it I when I started bright so I I
wasn't fluent in Spanish I still am not
our first markets Mexico so there were
some things that just didn't make sense
and I knew that but I also was very
surprised that you know so many people
said that just doesn't make sense like
you can't can't start in a country
you've never been to that you have no
connections to and you you can't speak
the language and it was like the nose
and like what are you doing you're crazy
would come from everywhere like I think
um there was like maybe five percent of
the people i talk to you that we're like
really supportive and like this is a
great idea but it's kind of like i don't
know if anyone who here is like signed
up for a race that they thought was like
a crazy race but then because they
signed up they just did it like that's
how it works and it's kind of the same
with entrepreneurship and startups you
kind of just have to sign up like make
the leap and then on the opposite side
of the coin i was surprised by how much
you can figure out if you just do that i
actually I flew to Mexico for the first
time when I was starting bright and the
power of the Stanford network I reached
out to Stanford alumni in Mexico and
someone I had never met I ended up
staying with and my my flight was late
so I ended up getting there at midnight
he was asleep it was a very awkward
interaction when I was blowing up the
air mattress to sleep on his floor and
that was like it's a crazy start but
like that started that was my first
connection in Mexico and then it just
grew from there and yeah it was crazy
and it didn't make any sense but kind of
signing up for it is like the most
important step that you can take and
you'll test your limits but you will
succeed far more than you think you're
capable of and it'll only happen if you
sign up so it's so with fascinating that
there were so many people saying oh no
this isn't going to work who did you go
to for helpful advice so we'll go we'll
go back in this direction but start off
yes all right who's most helpful uh who
do you go to for guidance yeah so um I
think the two people that were most
helpful one was my dad who had no idea
what I was doing didn't understand it
but was our first check because he it
was funny because after I thought I
pitched it really well but afterwards he
like a month later my parents were like
sweet so what are you doing yeah that's
great this is like unconditional support
um and he he's a big fan of Jeff Bezos
and Jeff bezos's first check was his
parents and he kind of wanted to do the
same to me and just kind of believed in
me and so that belief was like you know
very helpful because I didn't want to
let him down and then the other was one
of my close friends Matt wall who's the
same year at me at Stanford and kind of
also just had this unwavering belief in
me and like you know objectively what I
was doing was crazy but he knew and said
you know I I have like I want I want to
write a check like I don't care I know
you can do it and it was like more
belief than I had in myself and that was
pretty incredible and inspiring and made
me push for it because I didn't want to
let them down great yeah I definitely
found mentors and allies in various
places so I would say the the first
mentor we had was Brian Bartholomew
who's here in the Tomcat center so tom
cat was actually our first grant that we
got in and tom cat gives grants to
Stanford students and professors to
transfer technology out of the lab and
so I remember sitting right there and
Copa café talking with Brian about like
oh we're thinking about doing this but
we don't know for to earlier what do you
think it he just really encouraged us to
go out there and just try it and
subsequently we've gotten into several
incubators and accelerators and has and
that has brought about mentors to us as
well and that has been than huge I mean
I think if you're if you're doing a
start-up especially in a challenging
space such as clean tag you definitely
need support and will if you don't need
any any industry
we need support and I have ecosystem
around you when one plug for Excel
scholars so actually our first angel
investor in came through someone I knew
in the Excel program so so like having
that network and stuff was really
helpful and once we got like our first
sort of angel investor in it just it
helped to bring others along so so
definitely you know why you're here now
reach out established network find out
who your allies are going to be people
who believe in your idea and believe in
you as entrepreneurs and they'll be very
helpful along the way to kind of keep
you going lalaine yeah same here um you
know have had many many bumps along the
road and some of them are really big you
know is this company's sort of
fundamental thesis flawed all the way to
interpersonal conflict you know and and
all of those are very challenging and
similar to what Jonah and Tasha saying
who I go to guidance were is um you know
definitely my dad so just having that
unwavering support and unconditional you
know you know perspective has been
hugely valuable but I've also built up a
network of long standing and deeply
trusted friends and colleagues and
advisors professionally and the ones who
have helped the most are those who have
that clear-eyed view of you know what
what is the right outcome how do you get
to that right outcome and this feeling
of empowerment and optimism that that I
can get there and so that that's always
been an incredible resource great yeah I
think my time it here at Stanford was a
volume in the sense that I get to build
kind of a social support network which
was probably the thing that got me
through definitely my program but also
doing my program while doing the start
up to so I was lucky enough to actually
take my favorite class here is CS 210
and so during 210 you get to form kind
of a pretty close relationship with the
other teammates we actually had a VR
related team and so I got pretty close
with my teammates then and they're the
ones that that I really got to turn to
for social support when things got
pretty difficult when we are going
through our kind of early stage vr
turns so it was it was great to kind of
have them and to turn to them what I
needed them so you're all at the
beginning of these ventures and you know
you're talking about these pitfalls but
I'm sure you have some big goal of what
success looks like because obviously
putting all this effort in anyone can
jump in first what does success look
like for you when will you know when you
when you've gotten there um I would
answer it a little bit differently like
I don't think the journey is so hard to
be honest that you can't you can't just
be looking for one moment in time where
you say like I've done it I'm successful
I think you know a lot of CEOs will tell
you like the moment the IPO that's when
they think you know if they're really
feel it and I think that's true I think
it's a great moment but then it's done
and then like what's next so I think
like really to get through all the hard
times because it will be very hard you
have to enjoy like every moment of it
every day and all the all the struggles
you have to want that after you like
believe in what you're doing and enjoy
the process and so I'd say like yeah
there are very hard times but you know
every day i'd say like you want to make
sure you're successful that day and
that's that's what will push you forward
and don't I wouldn't I wouldn't try to
like look for one moment in time and
just aspire to that because that may not
get you through all the really tough
times so what was your goal today my
goal today is to inspire lots of
stamping seems to go out there and start
awesome companies and not worry about
how many people tell you that you can't
do it but just if you want to do it go
for it and what you end up doing will
probably be very different than what you
started doing but that's fine and that's
important and that's how it should be
who else wants to jump in I think for us
and success is very clear and we what
we're really trying to do is change the
paradigm for how cancers detected so
through that journey and we are building
actually we've already built what will
be the largest sequencing facility in
the world by the amount of throughput
we're putting together the largest
clinical trials that have ever ever been
acted in the history of medicine and
building an incredible team with
disparate skill sets that have not come
together very frequently before and what
we're trying to do is really um you know
find cancer early when it's cured when
you can find cancer early in the stage 1
or 2 phase of the disease it's possible
to cure it by surgery and radiation most
cancers are detected late stage so at
that point it's typically palliative and
it's really not curable and so what
we're trying to do is entirely shift the
paradigm of how cancer is screened for
and so you can imagine going eventually
to your annual checkup and having a tube
of blood drawn and through an analysis
of that blood be able to tell you know
do you have cancer yes or no and if so
where is it in the body is it at a point
in time when it can be locally treated
yes i would say at opus 12 you know we
seek to make co2 great again oh yeah we
two processes Bigley we are going to
build a company is gonna be the greatest
company ever seen no I mean I for me the
ultimate success is actually ten percent
reduction in greenhouse gases globally
by 2030 that's kind of my big vision I
mean it you know clear there's like
smaller goals in between there I mean we
need to prove out our technology we have
D risk it we need to show that we can
run stabili for a thousand hours than
5,000 hours we need to prove out the
market we have an initial market that
we're going after which is a smaller
market where we're producing chemicals
for small chemical manufacturers and
then we have our larger market where we
want to produce cost competitive co2
neutral fuels so we have many goes along
the way but what keeps me going and what
when i'm in this for is to make the
ultimate impact of making a dent in the
amount of co2 that's in the atmosphere I
you know there might be more there might
be a more profitable opportunities and
kind of smaller markets but I for me
that would what drives me as impact i
really want to build this company to
make an impact on climate change so
that's how we set our goals yeah for us
success we hope is already happening
which to us means that
decision making so for professional
athletes we are we are targeting being
on the field and being able to practice
as well off the field so using virtual
reality to potentially even do things
like reduce injuries so for us being
able to kind of replicate that sense of
I can mentally practice in a similar way
and not have to put my body at a
physical risk to do so to us that's the
dream is to reduce that risk of injury
for athletes and potentially have to be
able to reduce practice time and and
help those athletes make better
decisions off the field so I know all of
you well and I know that you've all had
opportunities to do case studies in the
classroom where you're being given some
interesting strategic decisions you have
to make and so you had some practice
sort of in in in a classroom setting
what sort of strategic decisions have
you had to make that have been really
pivotal for for your ventures so far yes
I can start off so we when we first
started the company we were looking at
making ethanol out of co2 and the reason
being was that we found this huge value
proposition so ten percent of what you
put in your car now is ethanol and that
ethanol comes from corn ethanol and in
the process of making corn ethanol for
every ton of ethanol they make they emit
a ton of co2 so we could take their co2
and make more ethanol and Cree CEO by
fifty percent it's a fuel so we can make
this huge impact and so we went down
this road of making ethanol and you know
making it you know refining our process
we can make it cost competitively and
then a few things happen to one the the
oil and gas prices dropped and so it
became harder and harder for us to be
cost competitive in that market and also
it's it's a it's a really huge market
and for us to kind of prove out our
technology we have to be at a really
large scale so we ended up changing our
first product and now we make carbon
monoxide for a small chemical
manufacturer to you see oh and there's
there's a non-trivial number of small
chemical manufacturers who need carbon
monoxide in their processes
pharmaceuticals for example and that
market is much smaller we can produce
smaller reactors so we can
show our technology works in this small
market we can also be extremely cost
competitive we have like a 10x cost
advantage in this market for making on
sites carbon monoxide for these
customers and it ended up allowing us to
to not have to wait until we could be at
this massive scale in order to shorter
provide technology and it ended up being
a really great decision we were able to
get a lot more buy-in from some sort of
angel investors and other people who
were looking at our company they they
saw that okay we could bring in revenue
pretty early while we're testing the
technology and then we could use some of
that revenue to get to our larger goal
so it was a really nice decision for us
at least has been at the moment we'll
see how it pans out great I think the
most strategic decision we made er I
made was who to partner with on the
company I started it without a partner
and had never been to Mexico and so I I
was like I needed to be very
introspective and look at what what was
I good at what was I not get out I
clearly didn't have a lot of domain
expertise in Mexico didn't know how to
navigate the local landscape so I knew I
needed someone in country to co-found
the company with but I'd never worked
something like I wasn't in a class with
someone who had I work closely with and
that was a you know a great fit and so I
worked for like nine months with a
couple of different folks and just saw
how it worked out and some of you may
know that co-founder breakups are the
number one reason startups fail so this
is a huge decision I made the wrong
decision at first and then ended up
firing a co-founder although we didn't
make it official and like that step of
messy stuff definitely happens but since
then the person we did bring on as a
co-founder Pablo Castellanos has been
incredible and like the only reason
we've gotten this far everything kind of
comes from your team especially your
early team so that was by far the most
strategic decision and I didn't make it
right away I just needed more
information and and kept going forward
our biggest strategic decision was from
the beginning to decide what types of
athletes we wanted to work with so for
us this was research that we started
with the Stanford Cardinal here with the
football team
so we worked with David Shaw and Kevin
Hogan and for us we wanted to decide do
we go to a higher level first or do we
start lower so do we start with high
school athletes first or do we start at
the NFL level in which direction do we
go from there do we work from the bottom
up or go from the top down and for us we
luckily landed the Dallas Cowboys is our
first client and that kind of decided
which direction we were going to go so
we started with the NFL first and we're
working our way down high school now in
many ways the formation of Grail I my
company is the solution to a strategic
problem that arose and let me explain
why and so Grail was spun out of a
company called alumina which is the
industry leader of nucleic acid
sequencing technologies and the
strategic problem that that needed to be
solved for is that when you are a large
profitable platform based company and
your technology is rapidly becoming
commoditized because what you're doing
you're so good at what you're doing then
the question shifts to how do you
participate further down the value chain
how do you develop applications for that
technology and oftentimes it's very very
challenging for technology companies to
be able to do that it means a different
type of investment and commitment it
means a different kind of mindset it's a
different culture it's a different skill
set to be able to do that and so at
alumina and you know it really grapples
with a strategic question of how do we
continue to drive the engineering revs
on our technology but also be able to
participate in the amplification and the
ubiquitous adoption of this technology
in higher value applications and so
ultimately the decision was to create
something like Grail where you spin it
out as an independent entity and you
give it the kind of talent and the kind
of resources and the kind of commitment
and attention that it needs to be able
to be successful and if you try to do
that within a large profitable company
that's looking at its eps the company
becomes schizophrenic almost and so it
can't be solved for so in many ways our
startup is a solution to a strategic
problem that arose out of the
company so Elaine you mentioned you
needed the appropriate culture to drive
this type of technology I'd love to hear
from all of you about whether you think
about building the cultured or
organizations what kind of culture you
want to build and what you might be
doing to reinforce that you want to you
want to start work so fundamentally you
know the difference between a tools
company what we're trying to do is the
difference between kind of a very
rapidly evolving technology and
engineering mind set to something that's
very clinically oriented how do you
develop clinical evidence and the data
that a physician can use when they're
sitting across the table from patient in
terms of how to help manage that
patients treatment so that's a very
different starting point already
culturally in terms of the culture that
we're trying to build within the
organization and I like I said before
it's very mission driven and I think
because we're building we're bringing
together skill sets that have typically
not been put together before
communication and transparency and you
know conveying that mission is
absolutely essential for breaking down
the silos and I think it's a constant
it's a constant effort I mean that
that's actually one surprise is how hard
it is to establish and maintain culture
because if you really want a tight weave
within an organization in a culture that
binds everyone together and you know
those kinds of you know it's a real
challenge so I hope we're you know
continuing to do that great it was okay
yeah I think about cultural lot because
I even when I was here at Stanford one
of the things I really loved about my
lab is that we really had a great
culture there I mean we we worked really
well as a team people had their own kind
of task in their projects but everyone
would help each other so I really want
to make sure that was created at work
because it it's just it's not fun if
you're working in a place that you don't
enjoy you know enjoy working with the
people you're with so what we've done
and the company as well as what we do
here at Stanford would use a lot of beer
so we had a lot of lab socials
we go out every other Friday we we go
get drinks launched on the company we
have group lunches those on involved
beard just because we we work at a
national lab they don't allow drinking
at government facilities um but it's
even though it seems pretty small it's
been really helpful for creating this
sense of camaraderie and like people
feel really comfortable asking other
people for help and and working together
as a team one thing I've also done
lately is do one-on-ones with each
employee we only have four so it's it's
been easy to kind of spread them out and
I think that's been really helpful like
understanding any issues the employees
having they offer suggest suggestions on
how to improve the culture and to
improve the work flow of what we do in
the company and most of their
suggestions we've implemented and so I
think that creates a sense of of you
know that we're listening to what they
think and what they care about and we
implement their ideas and so and we've
become more efficient as a company in
working working together we've
implemented some really great workflow
tools once our company culture was
actually probably defined by a staffing
decision we had to make very early on
which was that a couple years ago in
order to do in order to execute the VR
pipeline as we needed to it was still
fairly technical so we had a choice we
could either hire engineers and teach
them at the language of football and put
them on football fields or we could go
the other route which was we took people
that knew football and we could teach
them to do the engineering we decided to
go that route which meant that for a
long time i was teaching
recently-released NFL linebackers how to
do basic computer skills and to teach
them to do some of the engineering
skills that we needed which definitely
made me a much more patient person and
involved a lot of extensive professional
development but i think it was great for
us and that and that we we decided and
we knew that the clients that we had
they speak football first and that was
what was most important to them and so
we needed to kind of key to our company
and cater our employees to be able to do
that first and so so that was what we
kind of decided and now we've kind of
come you know culturally defined by it
by that so when I was first learning
about startups people talked about the
team is so important and the culture is
so important I didn't really understand
what that meant until I started bright
and like just to make it really concrete
for us culture is kind of like how you
feel about the company when you're there
like do you have fun in your
interactions with other people is it
frustrating and then the rules that
govern that and so I think you know in
the first year or for six months before
I really understood what culture was it
was unintentional and as a result you
know people didn't show up for work in
time they didn't show up for meetings in
time interactions were really tough and
the number one thing that now kind of
defines our culture was everyone would
always raise issues they'd say oh no we
can't do that oh no we just have to wait
three months for the bank account to
open because that's how it works and
everyone just raised problems and there
were so many problems you can find but
then you know because honestly that just
wasn't fun and like I didn't want to go
to work to every day and like hear what
problems we couldn't solve I just
started becoming really intentional
about saying okay we're not a company
where you can raise a problem without
raising a potential solution and you
don't have to have the solution but you
have to present a solution because that
habit of just getting in and thinking
about what could be the answer then
become something you take into every
single thing you do and then all of a
sudden instead of saying I'm and
engineers are really good at this saying
oh no that won't work for this reason
because you can always find the smartest
minds can find a reason something won't
work but that actually doesn't build a
company and it doesn't make it fun and
so everyone just started saying oh no we
have this like you have to come up with
something and we were just would like
wouldn't respond to emails if they
didn't have a solution like look it got
it got harsh but now like it's it's very
it's one of the things people value most
about bright and it makes everyone's
life way more fun so that's that's kind
of a concrete element of culture that we
think about super in a minute I'm going
to open it up to questions from the
audience so you can start thinking about
the burning questions you have for these
really interesting folks so let's look
at it this room and there are a lot of
people here who are aspiring
entrepreneurs and just a few years ago
you were sitting in their seats are
there things
that you wish you had done or learned or
thought about when you were a student
that would have set the stage for making
things easier now I can think of two so
i want i wish that i had thought a lot
more about how doing a start-up would
affect my personal finances um well I
yeah cuz I you know my family lives in
Texas I don't have any family in the
area and I crude a little bit of debt
while I was in graduate school and when
we started the company we didn't really
have any money and even when we got our
first seed funding in we needed to
really pay ourselves a relatively modest
salary to in order to hire people to
really get the company going so it ended
up being kind of a pretty high stress
and burden to have to worry about my own
sort of personal finances and and I
ended up having to really cut costs
pretty drastically like I even moved
into my car for a few months to cut
costs and like get ahead of my finances
so I wish I had sort of thought about
that a couple years ago and had maybe
saved more maybe did job on the side or
something to really kind of reduce the
stress with that another thing that I've
done that I wish I started earlier was
um follow minimalism principles so um I
have minimizes stuff that I have
anything that's that doesn't bring any
value to my life or has a functional
purpose i try to get rid of it i've also
done the and I thought he's kind of
cliche in the valley but the the sort of
work uniform where you know I have 14 of
the same black shirt and I Regine's to
you know the same outfit to work every
day so I don't have to think about what
I'm going to wear when I go into work
I've also just tried to minimalize sort
of the number of goals that i ascribe to
any given week or any given day and even
to like minimize my thoughts like when
I'm in transit somewhere instead of
having these random kind of dialogue
going in my head I try to just focus on
breathing and really appreciate the
outdoors and the sights around me and it
has been huge in terms of reducing
stress and increasing happiness
and just this the idea that what you
have and who you are is enough i think
that's that's such a valuable kind of
mantra to subscribe to because I think
so often thanks for in my facebook feed
you see kind of what everyone has and
all these like great things and it can
be easy to kind of fall into that trap
of always thinking you can buy something
that will make you happy and just
realize that what you have is good
enough cuz yeah that's all there is
great yeah I think um you know just um
when I graduated from Stanford I went
into a start-up and that was you know
then the whole com boom has never
happened and then I went to a couple of
mid-sized companies and then a very
large publicly traded company and then
now it's call come full circle back into
start up again and I think through that
path one thing that I wish I had been
more in front of mine is think about
entrepreneur ism in a broad sense so I
don't think entrepreneurship is just to
be found in startups and you know just
you know looking for bootstrap and you
know very small opportunities I think
you can find entrepreneurism in a lot of
different places and I certainly found a
lot of opportunity even in a very large
company where you can carve out I and
identify opportunities to be
entrepreneurial and to get a lot of
progress made and things accomplished it
may not be as visible as you know kind
of being at a start-up but you also have
the power of a lot of resources in
different levers available within that
environment and I think that finding
entrepreneurial opportunities even
within larger organizations is something
that is very valuable to large companies
and so I would um you know going back I
would think about the term
entrepreneurism in a much broader way
great so I I don't think you'll ever be
surrounded by more smart ambitious
people and with a less of a failure
opportunity than you are at this point
in time if you if you try something now
and fail you're still in
will you still went to Stanford you're
not gonna you're not going to starve and
as life goes on you know you get it gets
more complicated gets harder you know
they're like the failure actually
becomes more significant and you're also
surround imeem if you look around you're
surrounded by so many intelligent people
that don't really understand that
there's a ton of risks out there and
that optimism is exactly what you need
when you're starting a company you want
crazy people will say no we can figure
it out we can do it and that don't have
you know 50 years of experience saying
oh no that's really hard to do actually
or that won't work for this reason and
so you know my advice and what I wish I
did more of at Stanford was just go out
and meet tons of smart people see what
makes them tick find something that I
find interesting and then just go try
try to do something while I'm at
Stanford it like again failure is not
terrible if you do it now and it's still
not terrible when you graduate but think
about the unique situation you're in
right now it is actually an incredible
situation and I remember thinking I need
more experience like I need to work for
chevron or another company for a bunch
years and I did it was helpful but you
know that I didn't need to I could have
done much more while I was in school and
again it's just like signing up for that
race that's the most important step for
me I think the biggest thing that I
learned out of going through a start-up
and going through the process is
figuring out what support means to you
and if that's social support or personal
support or whatever other type of sport
you need to turn to when things get
really hard it is figuring out that
early on so that it's not too late into
kind of when you're deep into a problem
and you haven't slept all week and
you're trying to figure out this one
issue figuring out and looking into
yourself to figure out what what do I
need and and if I do need to turn to
someone else for support then then I
know who are those people that I can
turn to when I need it because then by
the time you're there then you can
certainly kind of prepare yourself for
for that great thank you those were all
very thoughtful thank you so who has a
burning question in the audience in the
middle here and please speak up how
important would you say is hired
education like md a PhD to
entrepreneurial success would you
recommend an undergraduate to first
pursue higher education or go right into
tryna so i'm going to repeat the
question how important is having a
higher degree beyond a bachelor's degree
to get a masters or a PhD in order to
pursue these opportunities you're
probably a very different answers there
um it depends on what you want to do but
one thing that may be useful in that
decision is you can backfill a lot of
expertise in a company once you get it
started so you can hire a bunch of PhDs
or people who have had 50 years of
experience Zuckerberg didn't know
everything you know there was about I
don't know all sorts of things but he
hired some of the world's smartest
people and he just had to get the ball
rolling you know if you want to invent a
new technology then to get the ball
rolling you may have to have that
expertise yourself but i would i would
frame it as what do you need to get the
ball rolling such that you can either
start to get some traction in a market
show that show that people want what
you're building show some early success
or raise some funding such that you can
then hire the next person because it's
all about just getting to the next step
and you're not a one-man team like
you're going to hire people you're
probably gonna hire really good people
Tasha yeah I would also say it depends
on what you're in but I I would say that
you do need I think as a founder it's
very good to have domain expertise the
one good thing about computer science is
that you can get kind of like the PhD
equivalent knowledge at home before you
even become an undergrad I mean you can
you can learn a lot about computer
science on the internet and like for
free so if you're not in computer
science and you're doing you know more
physical science than to get the domain
expertise you kind of do need to be in a
school I mean if you're gonna do like
like nuclear physics you know you can't
really do that at home somewhere yeah
you don't ya so I so I I think with the
exception of maybe computer science and
maybe some other feels to where you can
get domain expertise outside the school
then then I would say start as when you
can but if there
something that you know very specific
that you need to get the main expertise
in through schools and do it i was
wonder there's anything wrong with like
going to school first and then then
starting a company i mean you know
timing does matter in these cases so if
you if an opportunity knocks and you
want to go for it go for it but i don't
think you need to force doing a start-up
right out of school I mean I mean don't
his work for Chevron and and you know
like that might be a way if you don't
have a family that can you know support
you and write you a check to kind of
help you get along like getting a job
first and like building your own
personal finances might be a good way to
do that and and then wait till something
comes along that where you have the
passion you have the good idea you have
a team that you can form and then do a
company so I I wouldn't force it if
there's not anything there that you're
you're interested in passionate about a
different perspective yeah I mean I
think um it's about credibility it's
about credibility with investors it's
about credibility with the leadership
team that you want to put together and
the people that you want to build around
you for that organization and if you
don't know enough but particularly if
you're coming from a technical angle if
you don't know enough it's very hard to
establish that credibility and and the
most excellent people the most excellent
talent in the world want to work with
the most excellent people and so
building a nucleus of that expertise i
think is very important particularly if
you're coming from a scientific or
engineering background okay good i
wouldn't have done entrepreneurship if
it wasn't for my master's program here I
didn't undergrad at UCSB where there was
not a strong entrepreneur and
entrepreneurial component of school and
so I think for me I wouldn't have done
it otherwise without the resources here
at Stanford great next question right
over here
hello what my question would be what
what was your relation with to failure
before so the question is did your
relationship with failure change through
this experience sorta so the first
startup I was that completely failed and
I remember leaving that opportunity and
thinking very distinctly boy I've got a
lot to learn before I want to try this
again and some of this may be
domain-specific right i mean it's it's
hard and with a capital requirements and
the the talent requirements and life
sciences and to to really start with
like a one or two person shop but I did
feel like you know from that first
experience I wanted to go through the
rigor of learning many from many
different opportunities before starting
with a new venture again and I feel like
with grill it's kind of finally come
full circle where you know I feel like
I've gained the maturity and the
knowledge to be able to be credible in
doing that so I took Steve blanks course
here the lean launchpad and so I
described that courses like a start-up
simulator we form a team and we did the
early workings of a start-up and that
was pretty much I would say like my our
first failure as as it start of it was a
completely different team we were
actually trying to build retractable
high-heeled shoes in that class as as
like the class project and we had kind
of founder issues I mean we never formed
a real company but like in the context
of this stimulation we had like founder
issues and it it really made me realize
that like the team that you work with is
so important I can't stress this enough
like Jonas said it's just huge it's it's
like a marriage you you need to find a
good partner to have the marriage that
works you know for both of you so you
know I got really lucky with the team
that we formed that you know we will
Kendra and I we work together for many
many years when I psu together and then
Nicholas we found in the business school
and we work together to him
this plant competition and even though
we didn't win the competition like just
working together as a team was really
insightful to know that okay we can make
this work we can support each other and
and that was huge so that was probably
like my first failure and started so uh
have you guys read the book I think it's
called the power of habit it's one of my
favorite books it basically argues and
this has actually been life transforming
I'd suggest everyone read this book that
things that you do on a regular basis
are easy to keep doing and things that
you don't are really hard to do I think
failure is actually one of them
specifically recovering from failure
gets a lot easier the more you do it and
it's really hard if you've never done it
and if you live a really cushy life and
something I didn't realize is that you
know we have all these stories about
great entrepreneurs are people that are
really successful and it seems like it
was really easy for them to do it they
always just had success and that is just
not true those people are actually just
really really really good at recovering
from failure and so I would say embrace
it like I failed at every stage of my
life and progressively I just got better
and better at failing and recovering I
mean even Chevron like it was a disaster
trying to get Chevron to really scale up
renewable energy and we faced so many
barriers and that just really hardened
me and it was nothing like the failures
and challenges that came when i was
starting bright but i just started to
get to this point where I was like not
afraid of challenges anymore I was like
I don't know how I'm going to solve this
but I know I've solved all the other
ones and so I know I know it will happen
and I was just in that habit and so it
was possible and I there's you know
there's two reasons startups fail you
run out of money or you quit and you
could say you know it all really boils
up into you just quitting because if you
run out of money you're and you decide
to quit you're quitting and so how can
you make yourself not want to quit and
not quit just keep going I've learned to
develop a sense of humor around failure
I think that's really getting through
some of our hard times kind of age old
mantra tragedy plus time equals comedy
so if you're able to kind of have a
light-hearted sense about it it can help
you kind of push forward and try
great another question way back and back
two quick questions how anybody can even
if you share your journey of finding a
mentor and how you succeeded in finding
that particular mentor what kind of road
bumps you hit in that search second one
how did you thank you first hire that
came outside of your immediate network
so how does it work out so the question
had to do with mentors about finding a
mentor and the second had to do with
your first hire you know how did you
convince the first person that you
weren't crazy and that they're going to
join your team who wants to jump in I
always thought that um that I needed one
mentor for everything and I think I
realized that you probably want to have
like a mentor for every single thing you
need help on no one person can be the
expert at everything and so I just
looked at all the challenges I had and I
tried to find like the one person in the
world that I wanted to help me with that
and a lot of it was just like cold
outreach like seeing if I had a
connection that person but a lot of it
was just emailing that person through
alumni databases for instance and you'll
have a surprising amount of success if
you just go and do that or at least it
works it works for me so figure out who
you want to talk to and talk to them I
think from from my standpoint um you
know there's a lot of luck I think
involved in finding a mentor and finding
someone with whom you have chemistry and
you click and you know I've you know
I've haven't many mentors in my career
but and great managers but you know a
lot of it you know does boil down to
luck but when you find someone who you
think is a great candidate to help guide
you or work with you on certain issues I
think always finding an opportunity to
provide Valley back to them initially
you know get on the radar you know you
know how can you help them think through
a problem or you know if they're in a
leadership position what can you do to
help them execute an idea how can you
bridge you know functionally with with
other pieces that need to come together
in order to accomplish something and you
know that that's always been a very
effective approach from from my
perspective
yeah I think similar to what Jenna said
that mentors come in many different ways
and places and you don't need just one
so for me I've kind of collected them
over the years of people that I turn to
for specific things similar to kind of
the social support that I was talking
about is you kind of find those that you
can turn to even if it's not something
that's specific to their domain it
doesn't need to be specific to your
industry or what project that you're
working on but but if it's something
that that they can offer social support
on I think that's the important thing so
I've always thought about you know who
are those people kind of over the years
that I can that I can turn to for for
that and that's kind of how I've
approached it as opposed to one specific
person that many defined in a specific
technical expertise great another
question yes no health and wellness
affected your decision making so how's
your personal health and wellness
affected your decision well yeah I I
mean for the most part my health I think
it's pretty good I don't know if any
major kind of illnesses that I have at
the moment but I do think a lot about
like work-life balance is and like how
to maintain especially really good
mental health because it's I've to be a
little prone to like high stress in like
anxiety sometimes so for me just trying
to integrate in little like walks
throughout the day and deep breathing
and things like that has really helped
me kind of like clear my mind and and
rethink about the task at hand I will
say that and yet doing a start-up it's
there are definitely times when they're
intense phases where you know like Oh
for us if we write grants so you know
what grants do we have to cut all rally
to get that grant together and so things
like going to the gym and
remembering to take walks can kind of
fall by the wayside so having other
people who are really supportive of that
and like can remind you okay all right
we've been working for 15 hours let's
stop take a break with will clear our
minds and come back and kind of always
be reminded of that because I think it
can be you can very easily fall down a
slippery slope of your health taking a
backseat to kind of the work and because
you just so driven sometimes and so
focus on what you're doing so yeah
adding little bits in and having other
people who care about that does anyone
else want to chime in I think it's
important to exercise every day it's
like the one thing that has helped me
maintain my sanity and keep perspective
and it's way easier to do if you do it
every single day so I'm going to ask the
last question to all of you about
leadership you are all now in these
leadership roles how do you think about
leadership and developing your own
leadership and you know how would you
describe your leadership style yeah
leadership to me means taking
responsibility for things that go wrong
of which you know we've had a few things
go wrong and so I think owning up to
those things and especially when you're
when you're leading a team and the
responsibility falls on you know
multiple people for that then then that
ultimately reflects on you so so being
able to as a leader to accept those
things and understand when you're
running a startup that there are you
know financial and other consequences
that come out of that of which are you
know fairly large being able to kind of
prepare for those scenarios and being
able to you know it expect me what will
you do when you have to accept some of
those consequences I think for me
leadership is a couple of things the
first is a leadership by example and so
I think we're all responsible for
modeling the behaviors and valleys that
we want surrounding us at our other
companies and the other element of it is
empowerment so I think you know it's
amazing
what people can do when they feel like
they own something they're accountable
for it they're responsible for it and
they have the the trust from you as a
leader to be able to do a great job and
that you'll help them if they trip and
so I think that sort of empowerment is
incredibly no fulfilling and and I have
experienced that for myself and so
that's what I try to model as well I
just want to reiterate that last point I
totally agree i think empowering others
it's like one of the most important
things you can do as a leader I'm good
at a couple things and i'm not good at a
ton of things and so the only way you
can make progress is if you really
enable others and it's really scary just
so you know to just like hand over you
especially if you start a company to
hand over your baby and say like no you
make the decision like I trust you you
have you have more information than I do
which by the way you'll never have
enough information and so other people
probably that are closer to the
opportunity will have way more so just
figure out how to start letting you like
higher well so you can let go trust
those people enable those people they'll
step up way more than you think and I
think well that's that's worked really
well for us yeah I would agree with
everything that was said and also just
kind of maintaining the big picture
knowing where you're going with the
vision what are the goals where their
intermediate goals and like
communicating that and make sure
everyone's on the same page well I'm
sure you'd agree this was really really
interesting thank you so much to all of
our fabulous wreck
[Applause]